YouTube has given a preview to his
creators about some of the changes
coming down the pike cue the panic so
this is an unscheduled video it's a next
one this week because yeah this is
moving fast and I have thoughts so if
you had not heard depending on what kind
of youtubers you subscribe to you may
have already heard some version of this
but YouTube has a change coming out now
every time YouTube changes anything be
it the algorithm the Terms of Service or
anything else it basically sends
shockwaves every time historically it's
been because they're really bad at
communicating that to anybody now to
their credit this is basically them they
sent out a note a heads up to all of
their creators that the chain the Terms
of Service are changing and there was a
link to be able to see what they're
going to be changing to starting in
December starting next month so there
was a bit of a heads-up that's more than
we usually get so you know points for
that
but there are there's basically one
specific segment that is new on the new
terms and service that has a lot of
people freaking out so I want to talk
about what that is why it in why I
believe YouTube is doing it and doing it
the way they did it and then what the
concerns are so the there are a number
of changes to this thing to the Terms of
Service but the specific edition that
has everybody kind of running around
like chickens with a heads cut off is
this one and I'm gonna use their exact
words because there's a lot of summation
stuff out there and I'm always skeptical
of that so this specifically is under
the heading terminations by YouTube for
service changes YouTube may terminate
your access or your Google accounts
access to all parts of the service if
YouTube believes in its so discretion
that provision of the sir that provision
of the service to you is no longer
commercially viable so that phrase
specifically no longer commercially
viable as a justification for
terminating somebody's YouTube account
that has a lot of people worried and a
lot of people panicked now before we dig
into it let's talk about why YouTube is
doing this because they actually have
given us an indicator of that everyone's
freaking out right now about what could
happen as a result of this change and I
will get to that but first let's
actually talk about why this happened
and YouTube does give some context and a
reason and I personally don't have a
reason to doubt that the reason that
they give is what is behind this change
and for it being worded the way it is
now was this the best way they could
have done it well
we'll get to that but what they said
about this specific segment was let me
get it our terms now include more
details about when we might need to
terminate our agreement with bad actors
so that is a term that YouTube has used
basically for problematic accounts that
it doesn't want on the platform and that
would be things like hate speech
accounts work you know recruitment
channels that are trying to get people
involved with hate groups basically
things things that YouTube is a bit
infamous for anything that appears to be
using coded languages related to all
sorts of objectionable material in order
to get it out there in the open all this
sort of stuff that YouTube wants off its
platform and they want off the platform
because this is stuff that when it goes
bad makes headlines and it makes the
advertisers nervous
so the problem YouTube has had has been
coming up with rules that will allow
them to get rid of these bad actors so
what they have opted to do is the
wording that I read you earlier now I
actually think I understand why this was
done the way that it was and obviously
like I said I don't have a reason to
doubt that that is the motivation behind
this new edition and you
even a motivation as behind why it's
worded as broadly as it is because if
you are trying to deal with bad actors
and and I can look at my own comment
section and the choice in the decisions
that I make in terms of what comments I
block and what people I block that
recounts from being with a comment on my
channel and I can understand their
dilemma because if this is a problem
they feel they need to tackle again
probably because the concerns about
advertisers so the problem with trying
to tackle it with really specifically
worded really direct rules is twofold
because if you try and deal with bad
actors by basically making it not
allowable for them to use specific words
specific iconography specific imagery if
that's not hard to get around because
with anything like someone's pushing a
hate speech agenda it is very easy if
they know what the rules are to remove
the specific offending words but still
be pushing the ideology so what that
means is it allows people to follow the
letter of the law but continue to
violate the spirit of it they're
continuing to put out the kinds of
content YouTube doesn't want its
platform even though they're technically
following the rules and flip of that if
they put out a rigid set of rules and
stick to that that means that anyone who
is attempting to talk about bad actors
and things that they do and try and
break down or debunk hate speech or hate
symbols or explain the iconography so
that people are more aware and can watch
out for it they would be in violation of
the letter of the law even though they
are following the spirit and not
producing that kind of content only
talking about it and trying to make
people more aware of it but they would
be technically in violation of specific
rules banning depictions or words or
what-have-you
so I get why YouTube did not try and go
super specific legalese here are the
rules because ultimately that's
something that ends up working against
them on multiple levels so that went the
other way and they went broad with it
which again I get my basic operating
principle and I've said this out loud
my own comment section is don't be a
jerk and if I think you're being a jerk
and I get to make that call I will deal
with it either getting rid of the
comment or getting rid of you and I
can't be more specific than that because
then it gets waved in my face but you
said you wouldn't do this like no the
base line is is my judgement but of
course I'm one person running one not
all that big channel it's very doable
for me to do that now with YouTube
they went broad I would say they went to
broad with this there is a lot of
concern right now as to how sweeping a
power they're basically granting
themselves with this new clause in the
terms and services so again let's come
back to that term no longer commercially
viable within the context of trying to
deal with bad actors that actually isn't
a horrible phrase to make use of because
some of these channels that I have no
doubt I'm not naming names so don't ask
me to but some of the channels that I
have little doubt YouTube would very
much like to purge from its from its
platform because it's scaring away
advertisers or at the very least is
contributing to a culture that is
carrying away advertisers some of them
are not small some of them are of decent
size but by using the term no longer
commercially viable that allows YouTube
to make an argument of look the amount
of damage you're causing to our brand
because you're scaring away advertisers
is in excess of the of the revenue that
your videos actually bring in therefore
it is not commercially viable for us to
support you you are costing us more than
you are bringing in we can drop you and
I'm pretty sure that that is the intent
behind the wording but up to this point
I've been talking about YouTube's intent
behind it this is the point where we
Chuck intent out the window and talk
about what they could feasibly do under
this broad ruling and this is where
people are freaking out and getting very
concerned so that term commercial
viability would mean and again I don't
necessarily think it's YouTube's
intention to do this but it would
empower them to do this if at some point
down the line they decided to any
channel that is
uploading videos but has very low
traffic say it's someone just starting
out trying to build something or maybe
it's a hobby maybe you're not trying to
be commercially viable but you do it
because you like it and you're building
a little community of your own couple
hundred subscribers couple dozen views a
video you guard tight with the people
you want well they have to pay for the
bandwidth and the storage for whatever
videos you upload and if the revenue
that you bring in is less than what it
costs them to host your content you're
not commercially viable which gives them
grounds to boot you
additionally anyone whose channel has
been dormant for a while they may be
deemed not commercially viable because
they're not continuing to read up the
engagement and so maybe views on old
videos aren't enough to keep it going
maybe maybe YouTube can chuck them this
will give them the power to do that or
even just a channel that has decided to
change its gears and is and like a
creator if they decided look I was doing
this and it got me a lot of views but I
don't want to do that anymore I want to
do this now and they switch gears to
something that they're passionate about
but maybe get fewer views depending on
their back catalogue if they've got
enough videos up eating up bandwidth and
storage space and their new stuff isn't
generating as much revenue maybe those
books don't balance and maybe they get
booted too so this is where a lot of the
concerns are and again I don't have
reason to believe that doing that is why
this rule is being put in place but it
absolutely would empower YouTube to do
it so to make a comparison it's a bit
how like the Patriot Act gave a lot of
broad sweeping powers to various United
States intelligence agencies to monitor
the internet the intent being to monitor
terrorist groups the intent was never
that they monitor Americans but they had
the ability to do that and we have
learned over the years they did in fact
do that so it is always a concern when
some group or company or who
whoever is granted power that would
enable them to do very skeevy unfair
unethical practices because even if they
say their intent oh well we'd wouldn't
do that yeah we have no reason to trust
YouTube the best defense we have against
anything is what the rules are and when
the rules are so broad that YouTube can
basically do whatever they want all we
have is their word that they're not
going to use that rule to screw us over
and I'm sorry YouTube I know this is
biting the hand that feeds me
we can't trust you we have already seen
how these rules that you say are meant
to go one way are used to [ __ ] other
things again maybe it's intentional or
maybe it's the algorithm not being built
well enough to distinguish between what
you're trying to do and all the
collateral damage but the point is we
have no reason to give you the benefit
of the doubt in terms of what you will
actually do so the baseline we have is
the agreement is what you have committed
it to put down a paper to do and you
have committed to give it yourself a lot
of power so speaking personally I run
multiple channels I have no particular
reason to be worried about this one but
some of my other channels I do not I
mean the breakroom of geeks just started
and that's not that's not even
monetizable yet that's not even a
thousand subscribers yet how long do I
have to get it up there to get that
generating stuff before they decide and
this isn't worth it and shut that down
my very wild channel where I talk more
specifically about my experiences as a
gender-fluid person I haven't done an
upload on that channel in months because
I haven't had the time to do it is that
now in danger because I'm not generating
continuous content and re-upping the
engagement over and over and over again
am I going to lose that channel now
because hosting the old videos is no
longer viable for the amount of views
that they get I don't know and that's
that's frustrating at best it's scary
honestly for anyone who either this is
their primary source of income or they
are hoping to one day make it their
primary source of income hello this is
really terrifying because it is honestly
a reality of YouTube that we are at the
mercy of the platform holder if they
take away our platform which they are
within their rights to do broadly
speaking and now they have pretense
under which they can claim to do it now
the only reassurance we have about all
this if someone loses everything
unfairly they can appeal but YouTube's
appeal process is slow and busted and
this doesn't help that this is coming on
the heels of a lot of youtubers
markiplier did a video not long ago
talking about this and I'll link to that
below because this is kind of a separate
issue but this is happening back to back
that a whole bunch of people are getting
locked out of their accounts for
quote-unquote spamming when all they
were doing was using a bunch of emojis
in a comment section on a live stream
and then they would appeal and lose the
appeal and not be told why or they would
win the appeal and then the appeal would
get reversed and they still lose
everything so again it's good that the
appeal an appeal process exists but we
can look at how the appeal process has
worked with YouTube and there's not a
ton of faith we can have in that come in
[Music]
what happened to this slime there isn't
much left what what is it what is it on
what is it all over now that it's not
majare probably could you shut the door
please
thank you the brownies smell very good
don't they all right now there is one
other thing that I want to address on
this some people have expressed
concerned that the wording would allow
YouTube to shut them out not only of
their YouTube accounts but their Google
accounts as well and if that were the
case that means you could be shut out of
Google calendars Google Docs your Gmail
all of which is kind of important now I
don't believe that's actually the case I
think people are miss reading this so
again during the specific word and
YouTube may terminate your access or
your Google accounts access to all parts
of the service if YouTube believes in
its sole discretion that provision of
service to you is no longer commercially
viable so I think people are freaking
out because they see that Google account
is listed but it doesn't say terminate
access to your Google account it says
terminate your Google accounts access so
there are people freaking out that they
would lose everything connected to
Google and be locked out of their Google
account and not just their YouTube
access that does not appear to be the
case that is not what the wording says
and I do think that wording is actually
pretty clear I don't think I'm
interpreting that wrongly I think we
will just saw the word Google account
next to the word terminate and freaked
out so what can we do about this well
there are a couple of things the first
is we can complain about it which
honestly does help in the past when I
mean YouTube with anybody when enough of
us have said loudly enough this has to
change it has
usually slowly way more slowly than it
should but whether it be things like the
copyright system that enough of us
complain the copyright strike system
which enough of us complained about loud
enough that it is better than it used to
be it still needs work but it's better
than it was a few years ago the entire
um not set not family-friendly system
that was automatically flagging lgbtq+
people that has largely been sorted
there are other issues related to LGBT
you plus content but I'm not gonna deal
with that but that specifically that did
get adjusted in it has improved and I
can say that as someone who puts out
lgbtq+ related content that used to get
automatically marked as not could not
advertiser friendly and doesn't anymore
so again enough of us complain that that
got better still needs work but it got
better
so just because this is changing and
it's changing quickly enough that it's
gonna it's gonna turn out the way that
it is currently worded but if enough of
us complain loudly enough often enough
for long enough it can and will be
adjusted and that is worth doing so the
other thing is that you if you have the
ability because that first thing we can
all do it we can all complain we can all
add our voices to saying hey this I
understand what or at least I'm going to
say I understand why you went broad this
is too broad but if you have the ability
to support any youtuber on a platform
other than YouTube I would encourage you
to do that so this is partly
self-promotional but like in my case
that's patreon and if I ever get to the
point where I am able to make this my
full-time job which I do honestly think
I can get there I'm working on it but
it's going to be dependent on patreon
support not YouTube growth I will never
base that decision solely off YouTube's
income I based that decision based off
what is coming in completely separate
from YouTube because I've been acutely
aware for a very long time that YouTube
as a platform could be taken away from
me at any moment there's only so many
eggs I'm willing to put in that Bass
so a way that you can help any creator
that you feel has brought value to you
to this platform to other people if they
have another means of supporting them
whether it be patreon whether it be
coffee whether they're running a
Kickstarter for an upcoming project
consider supporting them because this
platform as much as we need it and we do
need it it's too big to not use this
platform does not treat us well and we
need whatever support you can give us
off this specific platform so that's my
breakdown and my thoughts on the change
to youtube that's happening that a lot
of people are freaking out about what
are your thoughts on it whatever they
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's links down
there as well there's the patreon I
mentioned like subscribe as long as I'm
selling this platform those will help me
out too as well comments there's links
for other stuff below merch I have a
book all sorts of stuff all linked down
below click on them or don't I am NOT
gonna tell you what to do I don't have
the ability to dictate the rules to you
because you're the council I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned for as long as
I can stay on here come in what happened
to this slime there isn't much left what
what is it what is it on what is it all
over now that it's not majare probably
could you shut the door please
thank you the brownies smell very good
don't they all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]